foreign
[Music]
Ty so many times so today's video we
will create a website with the help of
chart GPT and we will not add a single
line of code on our own we'll ask jar
GPT to do all the work and then let's
see whether it can create a website
independently so let's begin but before
that if you haven't subscribed to our
Channel already make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and press the Bell icon
so you will get all the updates from
Simply learn
now if you want to become a software
developer consider this course on full
stack developer mean stack by simply
learn and master those necessary skills
check out the link in the description
box for more details call on the number
that are given below and they will guide
you to get the best course that can
upskill you okay now now let's open the
chart GPT and check let's refresh this I
have already opened my chat gbt you can
just login it and then you are good to
go so let's say hello and see
so and so again completely fine right
now okay
so what will we do today is
we'll open our Visual Studio code I have
created one folder which is Tailwind
it's an empty folder you can just see
that
so in that folder we'll add the Tailwind
so first let's ask the chat DBT to help
us install or set up the Tailwind
so I'll write
please
set up
the
Railway
let's see
okay
so asking us to install node.js first
and then it's asking us to
check the origin of that
okay
it's saying to install these
new Pro pixel JavaScript module
to add these components in the CSS file
so this is saying to add this in the CSS
file okay
so
let's check whether it is telling us
something useful or not
post class Contour fixer
okay
now
simultaneously let's check
the table website
how to install this
so here
it's saying to install this command
CSS and then in it in that project then
it's saying to configure the template
part
to add this to your delivery
configure.file then it's saying to
create a folder input.gss
and then just start the process
so as of now
charge GPT has not given us the correct
answer it's correct but not up to the
mark as you can clearly see the commands
that are given on the delvin.css
official website
uh so according to me many people think
that because of Charity the uh so many
jobs of the developers are in the risk
because chargpt can create websites all
of this stuff so I don't think so
according to me it's not that good it's
very good for the uh helping any
developer purpose
but it's not that good but let's see we
are in this together
so let's just open the video Studio code
and install our Tailwind now we'll ask
it to create so many other things so
let's see whether it can create that or
not so I have opened my terminal so many
people also comment us that how you
could open the terminal so I just used
one shortcut Control Plus tactic
to open the terminal you can also go
here
and create one terminal
okay
now I'll paste the line to install
Kelvin CSS in my system
so let's wait a couple of minutes
as you can see it's installed in our
system all the packages and modules are
installed now it will tell us to init
this project so let's do that
okay
it has successfully created the
configure file now inside the content
we'll copy paste this one
as it is saying to add these line
configure your template path add the
path to all your template file in the
file okay so let's just
copy this thing
and paste in the content
now let's save it
okay
so now next step is add the Tailwind
directives to your CSS
now
what will we do here is
let's go back to visual studio code and
create a folder
inside this
that
SRC okay and set this SRC we'll create
the file
beautiful.jss
hair will place the good okay we haven't
copied that code on yet
so let God be
let's paste it here
so I don't think so again that this can
replace the Developers because this is
not the correct we do
tell although it has given us all the
steps but
any developer can do the task in a very
short period of time it can just help
any developer but not
take the job of the developer okay
so let's move ahead
and
step would be
to go back next step to fill the process
let's copy this one and start the
Tailwind CLI build process okay
let's copy and paste it here
right
as you can see it's done in 273
milliseconds
the output.css is generated in this
file folder right
now we just have to use this file
output.css okay
let's see now
let's create a
file here
and name it as index dot HTML
okay
and inside that I'll write my Boiler
code just pressing shift N1 for the
exclamation mark and then the Boiler
code is done so we can change the name
of this
and let's write here as
side
using charging
okay
now
one main thing that I wanted to tell you
that I have installed one extension in
my system which is the live server this
extension you can download
and this is very helpful okay
let's open this one
now what we'll do is we'll link the
output.jss file in our gmail.css
for that so I'll write here link
okay
and inside this ring I will curve or you
can just write link and then click and
then right
here
style sheet
mobile
okay
good
what we'll do is we'll give the path of
the output.js for that dot dot slash
list
foreign
okay
let's close this link tag and let's save
it and let's just
right click and here you'll see open
with live server when you will install
the extension live server so let's open
this one
so this is working completely fine it's
showing that the title which side is in
20 minutes
okay or something
I'll write here
welcome
to Simply learn
and then
let's save it and you'll see it's
showing
welcome to Central okay
now the next step would be to create
now let's open our
charging Beauty
and
and we'll ride
create a
concept
header
using
let's just copy this one
in there
that's usually
okay
so
let's see whether it can give us a right
answer this time
it can
let's see
okay
it's giving us the code now for the
header
[Music]
okay
so it is showing us in the above code we
use Tailwind CSS classes to style the
header we set the background color to
Gray and this one is the property of
green color and then the text color
would be a white color in that name bar
inside the header we have a nav element
with the flex and justify between okay
classes to horizontal Center the element
space them out evenly okay fine we also
use PX4 and py3 to add padding to the
navigation bar cool
for the mobile menu we use the button
with the MD hidden class to hide it on
okay let's see
the code now
okay
now let's copy this HTML file let it
write everything shown here we don't
need this one so let's delete this
and let's here write header
and let's comment it down
yes okay let's
raise the code and check
whether it's
let's save it and let's go back to our
file so this is what charging created
for us it's looking very good actually
so let's inspect it
and let's see is it responsive or not so
this is completely responsive guys
okay very good
yeah
so
this is really very good okay
on Surface Dio
sl20 Ultra this is what will show on the
mobiles okay now we'll go back to the
chat CPT and let's
clone this one and
stops generating and let's say right
create
a
section using
Kevin
CSS now let's see something
okay
let's see let's first copy this one and
we press this
and let's see how it will create the
hero section using tell messages
so it has created this never really very
good
I didn't expect this from the activity
but it's really really looking really
good it's simple and you can add these
to another Pages just using the anchor
okay we can just fill the path so I'll
show you www dot
[Music]
dot com
so this one is okay
so whenever I click on this one it will
redirect us to the simpler but the URL
is wrong so you can just go back to
simplylearn.com
and let's copy the
and let's go back to code
and let's write
the URL okay save it and let's see
yeah this is how this works
let's close this one okay now let's see
what is the code
okay let's copy this code and let's see
how this is working so it is also giving
us the complete code how it's working
how this step is working and all as you
can see it's giving us the max W with
seven into one utility sets as Max
weight for the container
7xl which is 120 112 Ram or 1792 pixels
it's giving us all the explanation for
the gold it has written for us so let's
check it
and after the header I'll paste that
code and let's save it and see
okay
this is really really good guys
yeah I didn't expect this from chargpt
but it's looking very good
so
till if I am a developer so if I had to
write this much of code it'll take me
around
two three hours at least but with the
help of charge GPT it only created in
5-10 minutes
so this is very good actually now let's
open the charge DPT again and here we'll
create a
in publishing section
s
information
using
impairment
let's see now
till now it's working really very good
now it is writing a code for us so as
you can see
let's see
again very good
now let's copy this one and paste it
under this
David
and let's check
so this is the information section this
has created for us
right important information location
office hours contact us and all right we
can also regenerate it for something
else okay now we it will create
something else for us
right
if you don't like something we can just
regenerate and create another one for
just
let's copy this one
now it's
telling us everything about the gold
and here after that I'll write this save
it
let's check what's this okay this is the
information section it has created for
us that this is something change data
and if you don't like this one also you
can again regenerate the response this
is really an amazing feature of Cat DVD
okay so now it's creating the third
option we can countlessly ask him to
create again and again for us
the response
let's copy this one
okay
and let's remove all of it because
it's looking very
now let's see okay
this information section is information
section Welcome to our website this is
what it's written
okay
now let's ask him to create something
else okay
let's copy this text create information
same and paste it using Tailwind with
one image I'll
check whether it can a response to my
things if I want to create one image on
the left or right side and then the text
on the other side let's see whether it
can create it for us or not okay
create informative section using charge
Duty with one image on the
right
and
text on the
left
side
now let's see
where it can create that or not for us
right just in simple
command so we will check whether you can
create or add the image
okay assuming the process called
text
okay
which class also
and it's taking the source from
an API called unsplash I have covered
this unsplashed API on my previous
videos okay okay now let's copy this and
paste it on our code let's delete this
one and
paste this one on the website
okay
so the image is quite large we can
reduce the sizes but in the starting
only I have told you I will not add
anything in the code so I'm not doing
anything in the code right so we can
change the size it's really good as I
have told him to add the image on the
right side and the text on the left side
it's doing the same for the user so this
is really very helpful for the developer
but as I have already told you it cannot
replace the developers because I'm the
developer I only knows how to do things
as I have showed you that it has given
me so many wrong answers before that
report this one
this I have given me three answers but
it was not up to the mark so I had to
told him that took uh create like this
image on the right and I've explained it
to the HR GPT then it created this one
for us okay and whenever I'll we refresh
this page the image will get changed
this is the
unflash API how this works okay we can
change the images also
this is random just right here
coding okay
now you will see the images that will
come here okay
let's see
let's check it
that's not taking any other name
but let's not waste time on this
random is also fine
till now it's looking really very good
okay
now the next step would be to add the
service section okay so let's uh charge
the video to create service section okay
foreign
now let's see
it's coming
okay
during the class for the side of the
water
really good
look how beautifully it has been created
right
yeah
okay
let's see
it's done now let's copy the code and go
to our location
and here
will write this code and let's paste it
now let's check
okay
so it's not a line straight but we can
align it
so it's showing us that the services
that this website is providing what we
offer and this is some junk data we have
designed by marketing and all
so let's check whether it is
yeah
okay
so
what this one is doing here is it's
using only
between classes until using
and the center Center
we all are using the same class but
let's find out why the
image
is coming
like that
right
you can align it
you were guys you want me to align this
we can align this right
okay
so
that's just a length one it's just one
line okay we can align that
so let's dig deep into this quote
okay
this image classes
same this device enter and then it's
using the flex shrink function
towards round and large
okay
sex
check
[Music]
and let's go back to the chord
strictly the size of this because
okay
go back to the Chart again
we generate the new response and let's
see how the second response is looking
right
that's a couple of seconds more
okay let's see the response that it is
creating
we need a minimalist design okay I will
just observing the code
and
you
you okay
you can also change the color of the
customizable this website on our own but
it's really very good I'm really
impressed with this this really will
help developers creating websites
okay
let's go back
still creating
after that we'll create the about
section for the page okay
[Music]
so again giving us that
design and all part
if I'll tell charge UT to create this
service action and this is my
requirement and all it will definitely
create that I guess now I'm always
really impressed with the code clean
code it's writing
and it's also responsive I haven't told
it to create the responsive code but
it's really really good it's a
responsive and I'll show you
and inspect I will just fill that only
whether it is responsive or not if you
will see I will have been test cut this
card
it's just
yeah so this is how we'll check the
responsive click and let's
see
that these three
uh home about contacts are managed
and
this is the header bar that we created
and then out one is the navbar this is
the information section
and services section is also there
this is all responsive
okay
so we will check how it's looking
this is how it's
it's really good yeah let's move on to
the code copy this code and coming back
to the code editor let's delete this
section
okay
now let's paste it and see
it's killing us
you know this is what it created for us
and I guess
a little less
or
it was already writing the code and it
stopped
it's fine it's not its mistake then stop
and
regenerate the response
let's copy this again
coming back to the
chart
or things
refreshed rgbt again
service section let's see
it's really fast now
okay
let's observe this one first
Services what we offer
we have design here must some lines
about digital marketing and I'm thinking
there is also
ah one part which I cut down
not something charging mistake it was
mine because I stopped generating the
response
okay
really good let's copy this text now and
paste it under
and let's delete this and paste it
let's check this time
so
this is how this one is looking now
this is also really looking very good we
can decrease the size of this image do
not worry about that
this is the service our services and
some junk data here we can write this
website is providing this and that okay
service one that we provide this service
we provide this service and we provide
this service okay this is all about that
right really very good really very good
it's really really good
okay you can change everything from it
customize it on our R means thing
let's just go back okay
this one is looking good okay now let's
ask Jr GPD to create the about page for
us so we'll write create
so I think
um meanwhile it's writing the code for
us I wanted to tell you that strategy is
great from for everyone
but as I know the code how this code is
working I know what is section what is
their class and what are the function in
this grid system that's using max weight
it's using the Excel function and I know
everything about it and if you are a
fresher or you don't know about anything
about the coding uh I think you should
first know about the language or the
framework then only ask this to charge
gbt or take help from the chat Unity
right if you don't know about the
language or the framework and you'll
just tell that activity to create this
and this for us it's easy it will create
for you but it will not
help you in your future
so according to me just
yeah
use it to learn not to
work okay
so
let's move ahead
and the path is given
okay
it was again managed oh let's ask it
again
responsive
about
section
using
table
okay I just mentioned but it
is very intelligent
I misspelled the Tailwind spelling and
then it corrected it
very good
so this is not the complete code for the
about page I'll ask to
and T and then it will take this command
or not
right right so let's see
after this about section we'll create
this contact page and then we'll
create find this website right
so this is really really helpful for the
developers I must say
so
let's copy this and
code and paste it under this
section
okay
this is how the about page is looking
really very good the image in size is
500 into 500 it's really really big so
we can change the size of the image
let's see
that is that
type 250
to 50
and then it will not come again
let's just delete the source
of in the unsplash
for the random image
right
that command is really useful
okay to add that
this is how like this about this looking
really very good guys really very good
if I tell a chargeable to create this on
the right side or this image I want on
the left hand side or right hand side it
will definitely look for us as I have
given him the
uh task in this section information
section it definitely worked
so I must say it's really really good
so
now let's move on to the
contact page okay
let's here write create
a responsive
contact
section
using
L1
and I'll ask him to do add some sections
for us so let's see whether it can take
up that or not
okay let's do it in a second shot let's
first and see how is the contact Section
is looking then we'll tell him to
improvise that
so it's just taking a section class
inside that section class and choosing
some classes which is legs wrap and all
and it's giving us
it's really important
let's copy this text again and paste it
here
so the contact us is also looking very
good get in touch and then it will
redirect us to the
button really good
the images sizes are
[Music]
large but we can reduce it it's not a
big deal but it's all looking very good
right
so one thing is left is the footer part
let's ask it to create a filter for us
no
okay this is the last and final step for
this
create
so put
the section
using
and
thank you
this is really very good looking very
good let's add the
splash
and then
use it here
so this is
how
it's looking down
so overall if I see it really given us a
good good output really
so I will say charge GPT can only help
us that's it
as this code that is created by charity
for us we can't use it directly this
structure that charity created for us is
good but we need to add so many things
before deploying it right if I'll see
this one we need to add this services in
the center and we need to uh
arrange the text and these Services we
need to change the size of the services
if the client wants it
horizontally then we have to change that
we need to change this image size as in
front of you I changes email sizes I use
the different apis
so overall it's very good but there are
so many things that we have to do okay
and for that developers are needed
so with this we have read the end of
this video I'm sure you will like this
video please give it a thumbs up
subscribe to simply done thank you
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign